[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau 7,8 loisirs
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence au tout avec le sommaire de ce
numéro les pionniers du street art en
france dans les années 80 les artistes
du collectif banlieues banlieues sont de
retour dans une exposition guyancourt
présente une cinquantaine d'oeuvres
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui nous parlerons
des spectacles à venir à montigny le
bretonneux josé cachant adjoint au maire
délégué à la culture nous présentera
notamment le marchand de venise célèbre
pièce de william shakespeare qui sera
jouée à la salle jacques brel
enfin mélanie poker nous emmènera dans
le grand nord à la rencontre des inuits
avec la pièce look à découvrir au
théâtre de saint quentin en yvelines
mais on commence au but avec une
information importante aussi vous avez
réservé ou gagner votre place sur notre
antenne pour le concert de salif keita
ce samedi au prisme d'elancourt
la date a été annulée en raison d'un
problème de santé de l'artiste
il a été hospitalisé il ya deux jours la
date devrait être reportée au mois de
mai on écoute un mot de la salle annexe
été annulée donc le confrère de penguin
ensemble de la tournée prévue sur moi de
temps pour des raisons de santé
là nous attendons d'avoir de connaître
la possibilité de report gens seront
puisse nous avons amélioré notre capteur
pour leur propre audace et leur
expliquer les modalités de change et ce
week-end le 14e open de tennis de la
verrière touche à sa fin les finales
auront lieu dimanche au parc sportif
philippe cousteau
organisé par l'association de tennis de
la ville ce tournoi a rassemblé 140
joueurs on écoute le président du
tennis-club de la verrière
nous avons deux finales hommes et une
finale promet une file à dam les finales
ont lieu en parallèle à 14h30 dimanche
prochain nous espérons que les
conditions climatiques seront optimum
pour six finales la motivation c'était
justement de faire connaître
le club de donner une bonne image de la
verrière en plus on avait bien choisi
des dates qui correspondait à un trou
dans le calendrier
c'est maintenant le moment de parler une
musique et théâtre josé cacha adjoint au
maire délégué à la culture de montigny
le bretonneux nous a rejoint en plateau
pour nous présenter les prochains
spectacles à venir
bonjour josé bonjour alors à montigny le
bretonneux il y a deux salles la ferme
du manet et la salle jacques brel
j'aimerais tout d'abord évoqué un
événement qui a lieu ce week-end c'est
le concert de sinclair à la ferme du
manet c'est vrai nous en dire plus de
demain samedi 28 20 heures 30 à la ferme
du mas et oui exact alors du coup
pourquoi avoir proposé cet artiste alors
pourquoi avoir proposé cet artiste qui
nous semblait intéressant de le mettre
en avant sur monténégro taux ne pas
d'une part parce qu'il a un parcours
musical qui semble tout à fait
intéressant dans un domaine
musicale à savoir le funk amnésique
essentiellement qui fait partie de cette
programmation qui n'est pas forcément
coutumière gentili et puis d'autre part
une certaine notoriété aussi ne serait
ce que par sa présence sur les émissions
de la nouvelle star par exemple on c'est
un événement assez grand public et reste
des places il reste il reste des places
à un événement grand public je pense que
tout le monde peut y trouver son compte
c'est intergénérationnel donc ça peut
tout à fait bien se passer oui donc à
noter demain soir à la ferme du manet
est en passe et maintenant du côté de la
salle jacques brel avec une pièce de
shakespeare j'aimerais faire un focus un
petit peu plus important sur cette pièce
car c'est une pièce qui n'est pas joué
souvent c'est le marchand de venise et
s'est mis en scène par pascal faber
c'est exact donc cette pièce se
déroulera mardi soir mardi prochain la
salle jacques brel à 20h30
comme vous le disiez très bien une pièce
qui a été très peu joué
de par l'ambiguïté un peu de l'histoire
qu'elles présentent ou les je vous en
parle un petit événement sans vous
évoquez tous les noms parce que ça
serait un petit peu compliqué mais dans
les grandes lignes c'est l'histoire d'un
homme qui souhaite conquérir une une
femme cet homme est désargenté donc pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir se présenter à elle
et la conquérir il va faire appel à un
de ses amis qui est un riche marchand
chrétien qui est lui-même demandera de
l'argent un juif un prêt d'argent et
le juif en question acceptera bien
évidemment de prêter cet argent là qui
devra lui être remboursé au risque de
devoir lui livrer une livre de sa chère
si toutefois leur répondais pas effectué
un morceau de chair donc c'est une pièce
peut être assez un petit peu sombre
qu'on peut on peut le dire oui
d'intensité dramatique qui est très très
forte mais en même temps c'est un peu ce
qu'on retrouve dans toutes les pièces de
shakespeare c'est à dire que cette
espèce de mélange qui est tout à fait
intéressant entre le drame mais aussi
l'humour la bouffonnerie donc je crois
que c'est un mélange de tout ça c'est
aussi ça qui me paraissait intéressant
dans le cadre de la programmation oui
alors avant que vous ne vous en disiez
trop je vais juste bon je crois ce qu'on
regarde un petit extrait un petit peu
qu'on se rendre un peu mieux compte de
l'ambiance de cette pièce et on en
reparle juste après on se retrouve foot
us après
[Musique]
c'est exceptionnel louise est ce que
vous disiez c'est la pièce a été écrite
justement en 1596 bon sens quand même
une certaine modernité notamment dans
les thématiques abordées également c'est
shakespeare sa part la date du monde 9
puissant intemporel moderne à partir de
là je crois qu'on a tout dit donc ça
parle à tout le monde c'est tout public
vraiment moi j'invite tout public à
venir assister à ce type de pièces rue
mais je pense que dans l'ensemble des
pièces de shakespeare mérite d'être
d'être vu par tous les publics très bien
bon bah je pense que le message avait
passé merci beaucoup à josé question est
revenue sur notre plateau du 7-8 loisirs
et pour plus d'informations sur les
spectacles que nous venons d'évoquer
vous pouvez les retrouver sur le site
internet de la ville merci encore joseph
mercier ils ont façonné le paysage
urbain dans les années 80 avec leurs
fresques le collectif banlieues
banlieues est de retour en salles cette
fois pour une exposition guyancourt
présente une cinquantaine de ses oeuvres
avec des photos et documents d'époque
découverte dans ce reportage
un style coloré des formes géométriques
et des personnages qui sont de sortie de
quid urbain c'est la recette du
collectif banlieues banlieues
un groupe d'une dizaine de jeunes
artistes nés en 1982 à poissy l'un des
pionniers du street art en france hélas
ici on voit pas le travail éphémère
c'est à dire les fresques les grands
grands formats qui était un peu notre
particularité est une des grandes
particularités c'était de peindre à
plusieurs les mêmes supports alors ici
on voit des toiles donc finalement c'est
une expo un peu plus classique
mais c'est un reflet c'est comme un peu
des extraits de ce qu'on pouvait mettre
dans la rue des murs de la rue à la
toile du tableau chaque oeuvre est le
résultat d'un travail collectif marquée
par les influences des peintres de
giotto à picasso au récit se construit
au fur et à mesure pour moi c'est comme
dans les conversations l'égarement ce
machin on invente une histoire
elle donne une piste l'autre la piste
est bonne il à la suit l'autre prend
chemins de traverse
ouais on était vraiment des choses un
petit peu comme ça quoi mais en images
et en fait on se dit prenons tous que
les grands apporter toutes les portions
étaient ouverts et utilisons le nous à
notre sauce voilà des images qu'on
n'aurait pas produit seul et donc ça
ouvre aussi ça bouscule la posture de
l'artiste seul dans son atelier qui qui
peut s'endormir sur un style sur une
forme
l'autre vient interroger ce qu'on fait
un dialogue aussi entre passé et présent
parmi la cinquantaine d'oeuvres exposées
des affiches créées numériquement pour
l'occasion sur le même principe on avait
déjà eu des discussions sur les
technologies qu'on n'avait pas à
l'époque
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire avec ce
genre de trucs et si on avait eu ça à
ces moments là comme on aurait agi on a
proposé aussi un prolongement est à dire
on n'est pas une rétrospective voit la
lumière chez moore qui est venu nous
donner une relance plus de trente ans
après la signature banlieue banlieue
reste la même les affiches seront
collées dans la rue comme une
renaissance du collectif
et mélanie poker nous a rejoints pour
notre rendez-vous junior à cette semaine
on s'envole pour le grand nord chez les
inuits un voyage glacée dans ces terres
tout en haut du globe ou presque leur
fait le voyage on va le faire grâce un
spectacle qui a lieu en ce moment même
au théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines
ça s'appelle inouk et c'est une création
de la compagnie l'unijambiste mais celui
qui le présentera le mieux c'est david
gauchard le metteur en scène
[Musique]
donc ça parle de l'homme et en fait
c'était l'idée d'interroger ma propre
histoire
jeune papa je décide d'aller fouiller ma
mon histoire et d'aller penser à mon
grand père mon grand père était
terre-neuvas donc il partait de fait
quand il était marin pêcheur est il allé
jusqu'au groenland et à terre-neuve et
donc il a rencontré les inuits donc
david parle de son grand-père vous aurez
compris c'est une histoire familiale
qu'il a lui aussi voulu vivre alors il
est parti au nunavik une région
québécoise francophone rencontrer des
inuits
il n'est pas parti seul il était
accompagné de plusieurs membres de la
compagnie dont un beatboxer l os c'est
son nom alors dans la pièce il fait
principalement les bruitages le vent les
animaux mais aussi le kata jack
il nous explique ce que c'est et on
écoutera un extrait à la suite chez les
inuits il ya cette pratique du cateau
jack qui se fait par les femmes
principalement que par les femmes et qui
est un jeu vocal d'expiration
d'inspiration et cd technique assez
particulière et et le jeu consiste en
garder le rythme
[Musique]
c'est un spectacle mais on a parfois
l'impression de voir un vrai
documentaire et ça presque un
documentaire c'est en fait la compagnie
camille veut transmettre à tous cette
histoire cette civilisation qui
elle-même se transforme un peu comme la
nôtre les jeunes et 8 ne sont pas nés
dans des igloos il parle de moins en
moins leur dialecte et ils sont parfois
déconnectés de leur propre héritage mais
il nous qui c'est avant tout un voyage
onirique et poétique une heure de
sensation d'être là bas aussi dans un
univers qu'on ne connaît pas tout y est
les doudous la glace les pingouins et le
bruit des pas sur la glace alors il ya
peu de paroles ça permet d'être
compréhensible à tous parlons à tous et
c'est surtout très visuel inouk
c'est à découvrir jusqu'au 28 janvier
donc même pour les tout petits les plus
petits merci beaucoup mélanie poquet de
nous avoir présenté ce spectacle on le
rappelle à découvrir au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et on passe à
maintenant à notre agenda les autres
rendez vous à ne pas manquer à noter il
y aura du football ce week-end avec la
14e journée du championnat de division
honneur l'équipe senior de versailles
reçoit l'équipe 3 du paris saint germain
sur le papier les versaillais premiers
du classement sont favoris contre le psg
en 10e position
et si vous voulez les soutenir l'entrée
est libre et c'est la fin de ce set 8
loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro et je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]